dylan c sought for his eighth star to
zra 280 he's had a very good run at it
17 walks 47 strikeouts
left-handers largely because of an
improved straight change haven't done
anything with himself and the royals
have two on with one out and now
salvador perez who already has two
three-run home runs in this series
second phase as that ball gets between
the legs of grandau
and so the regular double play is out of
order
get the job done he did in the air to
center field deep
and now garcia with the wind has to run
it down in right center field
both runners will move up and we told
you it
sure looked like a windy day in chicago
and man that ball was hit to straight
away center field off of salvi's bat and
it ended up
in deep right center field the royals do
grab an early lead
brady singer making start number eight
his third career start against the
chicago white sox
it'll be anderson eaton and moncada
coming up
and this ends up in center field tim
anderson beats him
to continue his streak and bring up
eaton with a runner on
on the ground right to whit out at
second and that
is a double play four six three
[Applause]
perfectly done roll them over
so first and third and now it's your
main mercedes still
topping mlb with a 361 batting average
back to the middle not hit very hard and
nikki lopez will have time
to throw him out right-hander dylan cece
gave up an
unearned run in the first inning due to
a pass ball charge to his catcher
grand all and meritfield the longest
active consecutive games played streak
number 347
strike three slider dropped in
just to take in the sunday breeze two
downs
trickler tim on the charge and santana
wasn't
exactly a stock car down the line
two on anderson he singled to center
field in the first inning and then was
erased when adam eaton grounded into a
double play
got him and that looked like a slider
that hung
can't wind it down blue kc pitch track
says
it was up and it was an effective pitch
so a one-out walk to eat
one on one out to juan moncada
there's a good slider that started over
the plate
and then broke down and in on moncada
and brady singer has three strikeouts
gallagher steals there'll be an
investigation
we've got the sox files team honest
there he goes
this to first and they stay out of a
possible double play with gallagher
running yeah it was a hit and run
he wasn't wasn't a straight steal he
took off and lopez was going to swing at
that one but
so now whit merrifield
to center garcia is there to make the
catch gallagher
tagging from second on his way to third
and he will get there did he hold the
bag is the question
he's safe
payoff from cease strike him out
fastball get out of here pretty good
pitching
ends the inning turns away kansas city
one to nothing royal
so kansas city has got the one run on
the board you're one swing away from the
tie game the 1-0 pitch
hit on the ground towards center and
through as
marifield tried to slide and glove it so
ta is two for three
here's eaton tying run at first base two
outs
fifth inning tim's going high fastball
gallagher's throw is also too
tall and it's a stolen base for tim
anderson here in the fifth tying run at
second
[Applause]
eaton lights this up into right center
field it goes
eaton gives the sox the lead
two to one in the fifth anna will get
off to a great start this year only to
fall on hard times but got one to his
liking we told you the wind blowing
toward right field
he got that fly ball it was going to
scorch him anyway
however it just kept on going riding the
wind the line drive put the socks on top
so the royals trailing for the first
time today have a man on with
nobody out salvador perez the batter he
hit a sac fly
ben and tindy has five steals how about
that oh man how far is that going to
roll
keep going stop at second base
oh just forget the steal
we'll take it thanks for help but perez
unable to advance him
because he popped up to the first
baseman solaire is the batters
very high to left field the wind
is going to knock it down as garcia
makes a play
on the track the win has been a factor
so ben and tendy goes to third with two
down
doesn't want to see this one slip away
he knows the importance of this one game
splitting the series and maintaining
your lead so dylan cease at 88 pitches
will walk out
the royals have runners on second and
third only one out
and tony larussa brings on a left-hander
to face whitmerfield
and he hits a ground ball to the right
side and a brave bubbles and there's
nobody covering at first base
so the royals tie the game and they have
the go-ahead run
at third with one out now carlos santana
who's driven in a run in four straight
games he does not go and the pitch
is knocked in the air right field this
should be deep enough
back goes eaton he leaps at the wall and
makes the catch tagging is gallagher at
third
he will come in and score and that ball
almost was out as santana missed a home
run by about two feet it's a sacrifice
fly for santana
who gives the royals a 3-2 lead so
madrigal the second
eaten at first now mankato the batter
who has been very difficult to get out
with runners in scoring position
and it's popped up
three royals are there and it's ben and
tendy cutting in between lopez and
taylor
so singer is charged with two runs and
six and a third as holland gets the last
two outs of the seventh
madrigal with the bases loaded
and two out holds the game in his two
hands
and a little half swing and a roller up
the line and holland
has to throw from foul territory well
done by greg holland made some great
pitches to nick madrigal
to end the inning and preserve the one
run advantage
tim anderson first
tim to right field merritt field back at
the track
and one hops to the meets and a double
for tim anderson to lead off
it'll be a sacrifice for eaton as
anderson's now at third with one out
tying run 90 feet away and the batter is
monkado
there's a base hit centerfield
anderson scores we are
tied at three the sox have two on with
one out
four mercedes chased a high fastball and
it's into right field moncada
is gonna go through a stop sign and he
will be
out at the plate it looked like joe
mcewing
had put his hands in the air to stop
moncada but he had made the decision
that he was going to come home
oh my on the fly on the money honey
yes monty grundle that's in the dirt
here comes abraham
full speed ahead from 90 feet away and
apreu
comes back from a massive collision
to beat the royals two days
later they're going to take a look at
this
right over the tag it looks like he
never got him
it looks like i think gallagher thought
he was sliding in feet first
because that's what he showed oh
i think he might have gotten him on the
back side safe the call
let's see what will the replay room say
is there a definitive look that says he
was tagged
i don't know let's see say
saxlin